ya hemos hablado de las muchísimas
formas que tenemos para visualizar
funciones multi variables y recordemos
que una función multi variable es porque
ya sea que el espacio de entradas es de
varias dimensiones o también puede ser
la salida verdad y por ejemplo estas
formas de visualizarlo incluyen a las
gráficas en tres dimensiones que son
bastante comunes las curvas de nivel los
campos vectoriales funciones
paramétricas pero de lo que quiero
hablar en este vídeo es quizás de mis
formas favoritas en la que en las que
podemos pensar a las funciones y es
pensarlas como transformaciones vamos a
pensarlas como transformaciones así que
siempre que tengamos digamos una función
incluso si lo pensamos de forma muy
abstracta digamos me gusta pensar que
tenemos un espacio de entradas aquí
tenemos nuestro espacio de entradas
verdad y qué voy a hacer a representarlo
con esta gelatina que tengo aquí y este
espacio podría bien ser la recta real
verdad no tiene por qué ser un
como este puede ser todo el plano o
incluso el espacio de tres dimensiones y
también vamos a tener un espacio de
salidas verdad son todas las salidas que
podemos obtener con estas entradas
verdad entonces cuando pensamos en una
función en realidad estamos pensando en
una forma de relacionar una entrada con
una salida así por ejemplo si nosotros
tenemos el 3 y digamos que su salida es
el vector 12 verdad porque pueden ser en
varias dimensiones entonces nuestra
función f lo que hace es mapear este
número con este vector verdad y entonces
vamos a asociar en parejas digamos de
entradas y salidas verdad así que aquí
tendríamos esta pareja 3 y el vector 12
así que en realidad es simplemente es
ver de qué forma asociamos digamos el
número 3 con el 12 esa es la idea de
construir una función verdad y la idea
detrás de las transformaciones es que
vamos a ver cómo es que todos estos
puntos del espacio de entradas se mueven
así
el espacio de salidas así que vamos a
empezar con un ejemplo muy simple vamos
a limpiar todo esto vamos a quitar todo
esto para dejar espacio a nuestro
ejemplo muy bien así que voy a empezar
con un ejemplo muy simple que es una
función en una dimensión es decir vamos
a tener una sola variable de entrada y
va a tener sólo un valor de salida así
que consideremos la función f x fx igual
a x cuadrada menos 3 muy bien y por
supuesto la forma en la que estamos
acostumbrados a visualizar una función
de este estilo es con una gráfica verdad
y la pensamos como una parábola que en
realidad está desplazada a tres unidades
hacia abajo pero en este caso no vamos a
considerar gráficas para visualizar esta
función ok lo que vamos a hacer digamos
es es pensar cómo es que estos valores
de entradas se mueven a estos valores de
salida así que como un ejemplo si nos
vamos al 0 si nos vamos al valor 0
vemos que la función aplicada a 0 nos da
pero al cuadrado menos 30 al cuadrado es
cero menos tres es menos tres entonces
de alguna forma el cero tomará el valor
menos tres si ahora nos fijamos por
ejemplo en el valor que toma uno
entonces uno al cuadrado será uno menos
tres nos da menos dos entonces este
valor uno tendrá que llegar de alguna
forma al valor menos dos ahora si nos
vamos por ejemplo al valor 3 al valor 3
entonces tendremos 3 al cuadrado menos 3
verdad que es 9 menos 3 y eso nos da 6
entonces de alguna forma este punto 3
deberá llegar a este valor de salida que
es el 6 verdad es el 6 entonces esta
transformación lo que quiere hacer es
mover estos tres números a estos tres
valores de salida y con una pequeña
animación podemos ver cómo es que esto
ocurre
y en realidad aquí podemos seguirle la
pista a cuáles serán los valores de
entrada originales verdad simplemente
los puse por encima de los valores de
salida que obtuvimos verdad y esta es
una forma de observar cómo es que se
mueve el espacio de entradas en el
espacio de salida así que lo voy a
correr nuevamente y esto es muy bonito
porque tenemos la sensación de como cada
entrada se mueve a un punto de salida y
a diferencia de este caso que fue de una
sola variable y una sola salida cuando
se pone realmente divertido es cuando
estamos trabajando con funciones de
varias variables así que vamos ahora a
considerar una función que tenga una
entrada unidimensional y una salida
bidimensional y específicamente
consideraremos fx que va a ser igual al
coseno de x coseno de x en la primera
componente y luego la componente en la
segunda componente será x por el seno de
x
x por el seno de x así que para pensar
digamos en algunos ejemplos vamos a ver
qué pasa cuando ponemos 0 como entrada
así que pensemos quién sería efe de 0
efe de 0 tendría que ser igual al coseno
de 0 verdad
efe de 0 sería igual a coseno de 0 que
es 11 y luego tendremos 0 por lo que sea
es 0 verdad entonces la salida que
tenemos para el punto cero será el punto
10 verdad tendremos el punto 10 y ahora
pensemos qué pasa si evaluamos por
ejemplo en pi
pensemos quiénes fdp entonces fdp será
igual al coseno de pi coseno de piqué es
menos uno y luego tendremos pi por el
seno de pi persona de pie cero entonces
tendremos menos 10 verdad así que ahora
tendremos este nuevo punto verdad el
primero era para 0 el segundo va a ser
para ti y si ahora nos fijamos en cómo
cada elemento del espacio de entrada se
mueve al espacio de salidas obtenemos
algo más o menos de esta forma
ok y nuevamente es una forma muy bonita
de pensar qué es lo que está ocurriendo
uno podría por ejemplo preguntarse cómo
es que el espacio termina estrechándose
uap ayudándose y notemos que esto
también es es una gráfica paramétrica
verdad de esta función y así es como se
vería verdad si interpretamos esto como
una función paramétrica entonces esto es
lo que obtenemos al final pero sabemos
que en las curvas parametrizados
perdemos la información de los valores
de entrada aquí al menos podemos ver
cómo se mueven las cosas cuando vamos de
uno al otro en el próximo vídeo voy a
hablar de cómo podemos interpretar
funciones con una entrada bidimensional